[Music]
she is having to share a bedroom with
her almost 11-year-old Depp brother at
her dad's house nope you have new
information that your kids may not be
safe it is completely inappropriate for
an 8-year-old girl to share a room with
an 11-year-old non-biological
[Music]
sibling hey everybody this is John with
the Dr John deloney show
so grateful that you've joined us
talking about your mental health your
emotional health we're talking about
everything that's going on in your life
your marriage parenting who you're
dating your kids all of it you want to
be on this show we walk with real people
through real challenges give me a buzz
at 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com
[Music]
askas let's go out to waterl Iowa what
is that on Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure when he's like waterl
uh like where would Napoleon be and they
go to that oh yeah it it's waterl Iowa
it's waterl yeah guys if you haven't
watched It's been a long time since I've
seen that Excellent Adventure it holds
up it doesn't hold up but you should
definitely go watch it waterl let's go
out to waterl and talk to Alyssa not
Napoleon what's up
Alyssa hello Dr John how are you I'm I'm
doing good I'm happy to be on your show
I'm happy that you're on the show what's
up oh okay he well I'm questioning
myself okay am I enabling or am I being
truly a supportive
partner um tell me what's going on with
okay so I've been with my boyfriend for
over three years in the last couple
years I feel like our relationship has
pretty much
plateaued when I do bring this up to his
attention I feel like he weaponizes his
sobriety against
me he goes into telling me stories about
his past life and reminds me how much he
has changed since he has stopped
drinking and um I am truly proud of him
I see the work he has put into his
recovery he has done 18 e0 as a
person yet I come from a family of
recovering addicts myself and I
understand it's not a walk in the
park and I I I'm kind of questioning if
I I'm staying with them because I I'm
kind of used that used to that
environment
or I'm I'm just kind of confused right
now yeah yeah you've got a lot on your
plate don't
you yeah I can I can hear it in you um
so let's move sobriety off the table
okay well let me ask you one question
how long has he been
sober uh he's been sober for over three
years okay perfect so let's move that
off the table four four I'm sorry four
let's move it off to the side okay okay
Have you communicated to your boyfriend
what you need in your
relationship yes I have okay and just I
want to do a quick rapid fires okay okay
and he has told you through roundabout
stories about his past that he doesn't
really care what you need right now you
should just be proud of him for how far
he has come since uh 48 months
ago pretty much that's how I feel okay I
want you to live in that context for a
minute because that will inform your
next question which I think you're on to
something I'm very very very I mean just
astoundingly proud of him for getting
sober big
time and four years
later yall should have been well into
maybe round two or round three of
building a new
relationship and you're not you use some
language when you first started talking
which is our relationship has plateaued
I don't like that language because it
externalizes relationship the language I
like to use is one or both of us have
quit working on
this because the relationship in of
itself doesn't do its own thing like
people say well this relationship R in
it's course that's bull crap we quit
working on it right and so it's often
easier to distance oursel from the work
that is marriage that is long-term
relationships friendships employment
relationships it's easy to set it over
there and put it at arms length instead
of saying no one or both of us quit quit
trying and what I'm hearing you say and
obviously this is just one side of the
conversation is that you stood by him
where got sober and you probably picked
up a lot of slack didn't you yes and you
probably were stuck somewhere in the
fourth or fifth ring of Hell prior to
him getting sober
right um we got together after he got
sober okay so all right so you missed
that part which is excellent so you
carried you carried a lot of the
water and then he just wants a pat on
the head and wants to be able to do
whatever he wants to do moving forward
is that
right I I believe I mean yes and no um
help me
out I he does turn to me a lot and ask
me a lot of questions and this is where
I get a little to the point where I'm
questioning things um it's as if he
turns to me to be his conscience for
him if that makes any sense whatsoever
not really give me give me an
example um any kind a time he he faces
any kind of conflict or situation or
whatever he he always comes to me and
discusses the opening with me and um the
way he interprets everything
is in my mind not um remotely even close
to what the actual situation
is and I I sit there and I digest it and
just let him keep talking to me and then
when he's done I kind of talk him
through with how I see the perspective
of things
and then usually a day or two later he
comes back and he's like yes you were
right about that so that sounds
incredible to me what's the problem with
that I just I
just I just feel like there's always
chaos I yet there's not actual there's
there's a lot it's chaotic give me an
example walk me through it be pretty be
very specific be pretty specific with
me
well oh I don't even know where to begin
all right let me let me back out let me
back out a little bit further okay you
not want to be in relationship with him
anymore because if you don't that's
okay or maybe you want to want
to I just I just feel like I'm getting
kind of my needs aren't getting met
because I'm constantly having to
meet his needs okay there we go I don't
know I don't know if he can
actually meet my needs because he
struggles tell me much tell tell me a
few of the needs you've asked him to
meet just
to to listen and to to
um you know if if I if I'm looking at an
important decision making of any sorts
whatsoever um I I ask him and he kind of
just shuts down he doesn't that's your
life you you deal with that you know I I
I
don't I don't want to you know that's
that's not me and so then I'm stuck
doing it alone anyway you know and it
just um I
just really want that
companionship with him to be able to
kind of balance each other out
okay I I 100% agree with
you I think the challenge here is
for you to be in a non it's going to
feel un Hollywood and it's going to feel
unromantic but I want you to take some
time to be really specific about what
that means to
you
because if you're the smartest most
caring person he
knows and you ask himim hey what do you
think about this situation I'm dealing
with it may be that he's a coward in a
wimp and is self-centered and only wants
to think of himself that may be part of
it but it may be that he instantly dumps
into his shame Lane because he can never
be as smart or as good as
you and so when somebody does that a
gift you can give to that person is
saying when I come to
you I trust you a B I value what you
have to say C I don't want to make this
decision all alone
will you help
me and if he says no I can't do
that then you can say okay then you've
got some decisions to make if he says I
feel super scared helping you because I
don't want to mess your life up any more
than I already have but I'll give it a
try man now y'all are building something
completely
new I feel like I have done this
approach okay if you have then I think
your question is it your original
question is is a good
one are you done investing in this
relationship and here's what here's why
I want to keep coming back to
you you want it to be
him and he may have made a bunch of
choices he may not be able to be the
partner that you need
fine but you have to make the choice of
I'm going to stop putting money in this
account I
agree so are you
done I I feel like I have been
done what keeps you
together I guess I'm just scared for
him that makes
you uh
do you need him to be well for you to be
okay it's a very common thing when you
grow up in the house of people who are
recovering or people who have struggled
with addiction is to become very
codependent your success is relying on
their
success I think you just hit the nail on
the head okay the person success you
must be most concerned about right now
is your success CU only then can you
wait into the mess that is going to be
untangling before your relationship that
is going to be separating yourself and
allowing him to make the choices that he
as an adult can make and you making the
choices that are going to be best for
you now and in the long
run but codependency is hard hard hard
because it feels cruel to take care of
yourself in light of somebody else
making poor decisions
right
right have you ever been to an allanon
group no I have not I would strongly
strongly recommend
that both for your childhood that you
grew up with and for this current
relationship because what you're going
to find is a bunch of people who have
really wrestled hard with
codependency because in many people's
lives there other
ones maybe maybe in reality or um
certainly threatened that they would die
if it's not for you you have to do X Y
and Z or I can't make it it's a heavy
burden to put on somebody 247
365 but I want to say something really
really firm to you okay
okay if this relationship is not good
and I have a I have a sense in my guts
that you're hedging your bets you're not
it's it's not great is it no in fact
it's less than not great isn't it
you're correct okay are you
safe yes I'm I'm safe
okay
um you cannot keep him
sober you cannot keep him from making
bad choices he's an adult and he gets to
make his
choices for the first time in your life
you need to take care of Alysa
and what you're going to find is you
begin to ask Alyssa what do you actually
need and now it's coming clear to me why
that was hard for you to even articulate
you got to start asking Alyssa what do I
need what do I
want what I what makes me whole I don't
even know because right now the only
thing that feels like makes me whole is
making sure other people are
okay and they're unless they're your bi
unless you're your children you don't to
be biological they can be adopted to any
unless you're a
child you can't that's a scary hard
thing hang on the line I'm going to send
you a copy of building a non-anxious
life my newest book and I want you to
read it all by
yourself and I want you to ask yourself
what about this
life that I outlined in the book could
apply to your life which parts don't
and then I want you to Google the great
P Melody p i a m l o d
y she's kind of the the Godmother of
codependency this
idea and just read about her a bit and
then Google local allanon meeting and
just go once or
twice you can sit in the back and
listen and I want you to hear if any of
the other stories from the brave people
that attend those meetings sound
familiar to you and it might be a place
where you find
peace but all of this begins with you
taking a piece of paper and a pen and
writing
down what do I actually want and what do
I
need and One Last Thing Before I Go you
mentioned I've been out of this
relationship for a long
time now I'm just worried about them let
me tell
you his body knows you've been out for a
long time his body can feel that Gap and
it wouldn't surprise me if over the last
few months things have been gotten more
and more tense have become more and more
tense cuz for a former addict for former
somebody who struggles with
addiction that sense of somebody pulling
away from them sounds every alarm they
have it wouldn't surprise me if those
alarms haven't been going off a lot in
his life which means you the load you're
carrying is become heavier and heavier
and
heavier what I mean
is if you're
out you often don't do anybody any
favors by pretending by not putting the
hard conversation on the table in fact
sometimes it can be cruel often it's
cruel almost always keeping secrets is
cruel so think of hard conversation's in
your future Alyssa do those things I
discussed and circle back and let me
know if I can help it any other way
we'll be right back
this episode is sponsored by better help
hey it's delone and I talk about this
all of the time I love love New Year's
resolutions I love the idea of everyone
taking a moment to reflect consider some
ways your life is going pretty well and
some things You' like to be different
and then actually setting in place
actual steps you can take to heal and
improve your life this might mean making
exercise or great sleep of priority
doing a weekly budget with your spouse
or like I did last year making therapy
an important and intentional part of
your new year and if you're thinking of
starting therapy try better help because
therapy isn't just for people who've
experienced trauma or who aren't able to
function therapy helps everyone find
your strengths overcome personal
challenges and practice new ways of
living and working to be the best
version of yourself better help is
flexible enough to fit your schedule
because it's completely online just fill
out a short questionnaire to get matched
with the licensed therapist plus you can
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge celebrate the progress
you've already made this year with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right we're back let's go out
to Wheeling West Virginia and talk to
Laura hey Laura what's
up hi Dr Donn how are you doing great
how are you I am doing fantastic thanks
awesome what's up how can I help all
right so my question is um how you feel
happy and secure spending money when you
are financially stable but you grew up
in um some kind of extreme poverty and
insecurity oo great question so are you
are you secure now go ahead y are
security oh yeah tell me about tell me
about where you are now we're going to
go backwards on this deal oh okay um so
I'm in my mid-30s um married to a
wonderful guy um the kind most little
girls dream about like he's Hands-On
with our kids and great provider stable
but also is a goofball um so you sound
like you're describing me except for the
stable part that's so good Kelly's
rolling her eyes she's like no he's not
all right so you married a great guy yes
and and hold on and hold on
and he married an incredible woman oh
thank you okay and together you have
created what kind of life okay so um we
have two little ones a 2-year-old
one-year-old and currently pregnant with
our third um I am a stay-at-home mom um
he has a good stable job not we're not
rolling in the jail but we've crafted a
um very frugal life for ourselves so
zero debt
outside of our mortgage which will be
paid off in five or 10 years CU um we
got a really good deal on the sixer
upper
um and yeah that's kind of what our life
currently is looking like now okay oh I
love that you just said that I love that
you just said it like that because
people who grew up with not a lot say
that sentence at the end of every cool
thing that happens to
them yeah and not even cool things that
happened to them but cool things that
they have absolutely worked their butts
off for and cool things that happen
because they make sacrifices every
single freaking
day yes they say absolutely for right
now until this all goes away and I'm
back living in a
tent yeah yeah I think that's where some
of my well I mean not the tent part CU I
know my husband's you know would bend
over backwards to make sure that we're
you know provided for hey Laura hey
Laura yeah this whole thing about where
you found yourself now is not all
because of your husband you're involved
too you didn't you didn't marry a fairy
and he like no sprinkled dust on you
you've worked your butt off haven't you
I have absolutely yeah and I got myself
financially secure before we got married
okay and I want to be let's be clear
about this you said we've created a very
fr
life mhm I like to say you've created a
life of
freedom and people think of poverty and
wealth as um a dollar amount poverty and
wealth is about free or not free because
I know some very rich people who are
broke they're leveraged to their souls
in their vehicles in their homes in
their business
Investments very non-liquid and I know
some school teachers who I consider
wealthy because they don't owe anybody
anything they they're not going to ever
buy a house in Jamaica but they can kind
of do what they want in the world
they've crafted and you have done
that sure right yeah and maybe I'm just
not living in that freedom yet you're
not um because here here's why
especially for myself you've been
running your whole
life tell me about your childhood
yeah so it was interesting um which is
something people who grew up in mad
house say they don't ever say it was
terrible awful they're like it's
interesting well it wasn't a mad house
but it was a cult so I grew up in a cult
um and my father was a drug addict um
that's not interesting Laura that's
awful say it it was a tough
childhood it was it was a tough
childhood will you say it was an awful
childhood I wouldn't say it was awful
because my mom worked real real hard to
make sure that we were shielded from so
much looking back as an adult now I can
see the stuff that she was trying to
Shield us from Laura just because your
mom feel like I had a bad childhood just
because your mom worked really
hard and is a should be in the next
Marvel movie
because she's so
extraordinary doesn't mean in growing up
in a cult with a father who was plagued
by drug
abuse wasn't
awful true that's true a Cornerstone of
you finding this piece that you're
chasing that's so elusive to you is
choosing
reality yeah and both things can be
true okay that's fair is that fair yeah
absolutely because I can be a real jerk
right now and say your mom should have
moved you 7,000 miles away from
that true yes and I have worked through
some therapy and you know with some
issues I had you know in relation to
that oh my gosh you're so you're so good
at the vague game but listen listen I
almost all of us are parents for both
and MH and I know my kids are going to
have both and parents too oh yeah mine
too so it's important to speak truth was
awful kids should not grow up in Cults
where adults
are like have have you have to be
shielded from your dad or from the other
adults in your family Circle but fair
enough was money really tight and
tough yes especially um when my dad left
and then shortly after my mom dig us out
out of the cult um that was kind of all
one big her fuffle um and then yeah
money was definitely tight kind of to
the point of you know where G and I are
splitting a you know 50 Cent pot pie and
there's nothing else in the house so you
know we don't know where where the next
meal is coming from yeah
um but
then you know she did get more stable
she got a good job and um how old were
you when all this
happen uh 13 14 okay all
right um and then you know I hit my 20s
and didn't do college um but I did end
up getting a good you know career for
myself um that I was able to provide and
then from
there you know late 20s met my husband
then we got married and um you know
started crafting what we wanted our life
to look like
um kind of what has brought this up to
me that maybe I have a financial
hangup is that this house that we're
living in um it's it's a fixer upper for
sure um lots of potential
um but our next big project is kind of a
for me project which would be the
kitchen um because right now like
there's boards and stuff on the walls so
stuff doesn't blow in like it had been
but it's that's the kind of state it's
in um you kind of fix her uper this
sounds more like a hunting
blind no it's actually it's a 4,000
square foot Farmhouse
Victorian um with with with boards on
the wall so things don't blow
in well now there's boards on the wall
CU my husband wanted to see what was
behind the original walls to see what
kind of work and electrical needed to be
done okay okay all right so I'm going to
give you a couple I'm going to give you
a couple of of thoughts here okay okay
number
one a kitchen is a heartbeat it's the
chest cavity of the of the
family this is not just for
you that's like your husband saying hey
um I don't want to do something like too
um him being a a Craftsman him being a
cabinet maker and being like I feel
guilty about buying a uh screwdrivers
and drills and a saw like no dude that's
and I have no issues with spending on
that kind of stuff of course you don't
but that's his job yeah yeah and you've
taken the role you quit your career and
you've taken the role as
Homemaker and this is the chest cavity
of your family this is where the heart
beats yep build a nice kitchen for your
family don't borrow money don't don't
don't chain yourself to a credit card
company to get this done and that's the
thing we have the money for it but I'm
like well what if we have another baby
and we need to get another V you know my
this here this here this you're never
going to find peace until that what if
machine can finally be put to
bed okay and by the way I didn't grow up
in abject poverty like you I did grow up
in money was very very scary okay yeah
and so uh but not I we weren't split
into one pot pot I don't want to compare
what I went through with what you went
through um and I spoken extensively
about how I grew up but Dad had a great
job he was a good policeman mom stayed
home with the kids with all three of us
um but things were were dicey okay
things were tight and so a couple of
things have you heard me talk about the
GPS
pins no okay I don't think so so you
know like if you're going somewhere Zen
would ever Dro to GPS pin in their
phones for you to get somewhere yes okay
so your body does that
to moments that may have cost you your
life or that activated your fight or
flight it rest in your nervous system
doesn't have an actual GPS pin but it's
it's an easy analogy for me okay here's
a couple of things I think are happening
number one you grew up in a world where
those people redid their
kitchens those people not us yeah we're
not those kind of people we're the kind
of people who fill in what whatever your
cult said to
you so number one you have an identity
issue that's going against your nervous
system because the earliest wiring you
have is those people over there do X Y
or Z this is why changing political
affiliations is so
hard right because they are the bad
guys and you're we think of this as just
purely intellectual it's not it's
encodes itself in our bodies okay so
number one those people spend money on
kitchens we we do this they're evil
we're
great okay so your body put Bing put a
GPS pin in those people and now you're
getting you're turning into one of those
people your body starts sounding the
alarms the next thing is you're getting
ready to have child number three you
quit your job what a job gives us is a
sense of somewhat elusory that's
somewhat false but a real sense of I'm
driving my own
train
and now you're not quote unquote making
a paycheck you're relying on this guy
you
married your body put a GPS pin in
relying on
men because men will leave you men will
lie to
you men will fill in the blank and even
though he's wonderful and great and you
can fix all these things inside your
body your body knows don't hitch
everything to somebody because remember
what happened last
time that's number two number
three money could all go away it could
it could do you guys have an emergency
fund where you're your own
bank yes oh yeah how much like it worth
of months of
expenses um I'd say probably about six
to eight
months so all of your job your husband's
job would have to go
away yeah and you would have to not work
and he would have to not work for six to
eight months before you had to borrow a
penny
yeah the world would look radically
different at that
moment right oh absolutely so what I'm
telling you is you're okay like I'm
talking about like ash would be falling
from the sky and like the zombies would
be coming right that's right that's
right
because even if everything if your
husband's job went away tomorrow he
would be at McDonald's you would be at
McDonald's your neighbor would be
watching your kids and yall would be
able to stretch this thing out for at
least a
year yeah
yes absolutely but I want you to
remember this this is not about data or
facts this is about your nervous system
trying to keep you
safe okay so and that's why I feel so
visceral yeah it very much does
to this day money terrifies me terrifies
me it sets off a reaction in my
body
okay Y and my show is doing pretty well
we're okay we're doing great okay um
yeah and even when I went to the auto
dealership a year ago to buy a car I
went to go get one car and at the last
minute I bought a Toyota Highlander it's
an amazing car I could not spend that
money I had it in cash right here's why
I'm telling you
that you got to make
peace is your husband love you oh
yeah does he make a good
living yes if his job went away would he
go get another job he's that kind of man
oh yeah are you a good
mom I am have youall created a world
that is completely different from the
one you grew up in 100% okay your body's
always going to be trying to solve for
what it knows and what it knows is chaos
and what it knows is
a and so every time something new comes
along like stability it's gonna try to
drag you back and here's the word I want
to give you and it's bananas it's
practice it's practice okay do you have
a like a thoughts Journal I wish I had a
better name for it I'm going to come up
with a better name for it
someday I have about 50 of them that I
started with my ADHD and then didn't
continue okay very good awesome just
like my house all right all ADHD is by
the way is a body's response to chaos
it's trying to Wrangle with it y okay so
if you're watching this on YouTube I
have one right here with some stickers
on it I have subpop which is the record
label that uh launched Nirvana among
others Yeti because I want to advertise
for a cooler company Michael Easter's 2%
I got I got this and I carry it with me
everywhere you know what it's mostly in
it me writing down thoughts to get them
out of my body and out of my head and to
ask myself this one question is this
true we're g to run out of money all
right I'm gonna write that down is this
true now we have eight months worth in
the bank we're
good people who spend money on kitchen
remodels are greedy unbelievable they're
they're capitalist pigs they're feeling
is that true no will my family be honor
blessed and honored by the great Kitchen
yes we be able to honor and bless people
to let them come into our giant home and
stay when they don't have a place to go
yes will this be a warm place for my
husband to come home to every night
yes be a place that my kids are going to
bring their kids home to yes
right that's you practicing absolutely
okay here's a third thing I want you to
keep in mind mind it's this idea of
ratios okay ratios is what transform my
life my friend Dave Ramsey taught me
this Dave grew up very with without a
lot I grew up without a lot and then
Dave's got way more than a lot um and
but here's what he had to
say if you have
$10,000 and you buy a$1 thousand
car that's X percentage of that money
okay yeah so you can look at somebody
that has a new F-150 and think oh my
gosh they spent $75,000 on that car un
what a unbelievable disgusting
gross well if they're
making x amount of money then the
percentage might just be the same they
might be giving away a lot and they
might be fill in the blank fill in the
blank fill in the blank right so when
you grow up and you and your mom are
splitting a pot
pie that's x% of how much money you
brought home that month right yeah or
how much money you had now
um youall have more than that so when
you look at your groceries you're like I
can't believe we just spent this on
groceries just do the
ratios just do the ratios and as long as
those ratios don't get out of whack
you're going to be okay and here's the
last last last
thing keep your eyes open and give give
like crazy give like
crazy don't give out a guilt give
because you
know you
know you've been there you haven't been
able to breathe you know hang on the
line here Laura I'm going to send you uh
my buddy Dave Ramsey's book Total Money
Makeover and I want you to read that
book with your husband make sure you're
following those plans and then I want
you to give that book away to somebody
somebody who's struggling start that
path start that giving path
there but
hey send pictures of that kitchen that
y'all build I want to see what it looks
like and see how you honor your home how
you honor your
family how you honor the heartbeat of
that of that of that family that new
family that y'all are building we'll be
right
back hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow hallow is the number one Prayer
app in the world on planet Earth and
they're giving you three free months to
get started and people always say you
got to meditate you got to pray you got
to have a spiritual life and for many of
us we don't even know what that means we
don't even where to start that's where
hallow steps in three free months to
Prior prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the lowii station that I love
guided prayers meditations and more and
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hall makes it easy
to practice mindfulness build a deeper
more meaningful spiritual life to figure
out what you even believe in the first
place and choose peace and remember
hallow is giving you 990 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
delonay and follow the simple prompts to
start your free 90-day trial that's
hall.com
delone all right let's go out to Indiana
and talk to the Sarah with an H what's
up
Sarah that's the only way to spell it I
can't comment what's
up oh I am just enjoying this beautiful
sunny day Fant
fantastic yes how are you I'm enjoying a
beautiful SUNY day too except I'm locked
in this studio here what's up true okay
so I am looking for some help with the
situation with my youngest daughter I am
wondering who can help me advocate for
her um she is having to share a bedroom
with her almost 11-year-old stepbrother
at her dad's house nope out out out out
out out out out out out out well I agree
with you um let but let me tell you this
so simply asking her dad to make a
change in room Arrangements which is
where I started it hasn't worked um and
with other things that have come up um
it it seems that
he that makes him dig his heels in even
deeper in resistance because I asked
call your attorney call your attorney
today well let me let me I'm getting all
fired up about it all right right I'll
be quiet I'll be quiet I'll be fired up
too um so like having you know when her
dad so let me tell you another can I
just tell you another story another
situation sure okay so um I have three
kids they're now 16 almost 14 and almost
n and when the
16-year-old was 14 I found out that um
my ex-husband was letting him drive his
Toyota 4Runner around public roads like
not down back Country Roads not you know
in parking lots like to and from church
to and from the grocery
store and I called my attorney at that
because I pick my battles you know and
that to me was
red waving
flag and I really felt like the legal
system failed me it just it just didn't
go
anywhere and so this is why I'm asking
you for help and I hear you say call my
attorney but my experience when things
have happened and there's another kind
of other thing Brewing too I have asked
him to um not allow our almost
14-year-old they the girls both turn um
a year older in February so they're very
close but she
he owns a golf cart and he allows her to
drive it around and she drives it onto a
busy road that goes between
neighborhoods I have jumped up and down
no no no and I told her no no no I don't
get anywhere with him um so I feel I
feel very powerless
when you called your attorney did you
call your attorney as though you were
calling the police or did you call to
alter the um custody
Arrangement
um the attorney that I I used a
different attorney at that time than I
did with my divorce okay um and she kind
of treated it
like
we we can't do anything CU it's after
the fact that's
completely all right here's what I know
I know I have not I'm G to be honest I
haven't read the data recently okay it's
been a couple of years but I know that a
significant amount of abuse comes from
stepparents stepf
fathers and um that extended additional
Circle right that non-blood Circle
I do understand the tragedy that is
letting a kid drive a
car probably what I would do in the
future is call the police and tell them
there's a 14-year-old driving a vehicle
right now and have the kid arrested and
then it would go back to
Dad but I tell you all that to tell you
because I'd much rather my kid get
arrested and by the way they're not
going to get in trouble or 14 the adult
is the one who put him in the car um I'd
much rather rather my kid get arrested
than get
hit right yeah but all that to
say you have new information that your
kids may not be
safe in those three instances it is
completely inappropriate for an
8-year-old girl to share a room with an
11-year-old non-biological sibling
period period period period you're not
crazy
okay you're not
crazy I know it's never okay to let
children Drive
Vehicles
right now like the golf cart thing and
these little golf cart neighborhoods
that are popping up all over the place
that's a different conversation I
I we'll just have that conversation
later let's just talk about the original
one that you're like what you're telling
me is the courts looked at the facts
gave dad custody Arrangement a and gave
you custody Arrangement B you all signed
it and you left or the judge ruled on it
and you left
now you have new
information yeah I mean the the
landscape in our lives is totally
different I mean we've been um I mean I
we separated almost five years
ago next month I you know I moved out I
bought a house um we've been formally
divorced for four years at that time
excuse me at that time there wasn't
anyone else in the picture um he pretty
quickly got remarried
and um and brought and and she brought
three kids into the picture so you know
there's six kids and two adults
and you know I I respect try to be
respectful my children when they're here
I don't nitpick them for information but
when they talk to me about it I listen
very open you know open ears um I think
the thing with my daughter um the
this the rooming nonbiologically related
children and especially of different
genders that bothered me just if you put
it down on paper it's like no but she
also she came
into um when they all were at my house
she came
into the my son's room we were all
hanging out in there and she just had
was ready for bed she had on one of my
t-shirts just long t-shirt and then she
came back in there and she had she had
the shirt off and she was just wearing
her underwear and I was like what's up
and she said something like well if boys
can do it girls can do it too and I was
just like my mom's Spidey senses just
kind of went off and I thought that's
different that's weird that's kind of
not sitting right with me and and I just
got the feeling of maybe because she
sharing a room with a young boy and not
to say that I I don't think and when
I've asked her she doesn't say that
anything is going on and I don't name
him specifically and they have gone over
Safe Touch curriculum they actually are
talking about that in her school but I'm
also just not a dummy all right Sarah
listen listen to me okay yeah I'm just
telling you this from a parent of an
eight-year-old girl
no right and here's how I would handle
this if I were you you've been burned by
the system before okay or you you you
feel burned I don't know if the system
actually didn't actually quote unquote
failed you but you made a call one time
no one did anything they said hey it's
too late it is what it is
fine here's how I would proceed and you
have to understand that when it comes to
the health and safety of my daughter I
will burn it all
down yeah okay that's number one number
two if I've learned any
anything after talking with countless
young women I can't even count the
number of women who sat in my office
over two decades and told me things that
happened to them as kids It's
haunting okay yeah trust
every I would much rather you trust your
gut and be
wrong than trust your gut I mean then
have this feeling that you know
something's not right and you're like ah
well you know so here's I would handle
it I would tell my ex I need you to know
I going to call everybody on planet
Earth everybody CPS Child Protective
Services an attorney to try to get new
custody Arrangements I'm going to call
the police I'm going to call the school
counselor I'm calling
everybody I'm also taking our daughter
to a a child counselor hopefully she's
seeing somebody anyway about the
integration with a different family and
and you're going to ask for a forensic
interview tell her I found out she is
sharing a room with an 11-year-old boy
that's a
stepbrother and suddenly things have
just changed with
her okay
yeah
also I would contact the school and ask
them to keep their eyes
open okay yep now let me ask you this
this is a very personal question have
you experienced this before when you
were a
kid
um yes and no and let me just put it
this way I did not experience um sexual
abuse as a child when I was um similar
ages my my brother and I were Um how my
grandparents were visiting and you know
so we got kicked off it was like a
family event whatever we got kicked out
of our rooms and so we were bunked up in
a bed one occasion and it was kind of
like what happens if we touch parts so I
so it it's bothered me he and I talked
about it and we both had that guilt and
shame from that experience but I did not
repe you know have any sort of repeated
sexual abuse or trauma how old was
he he was 11 how old were you
seven but I came to find out after that
that he um younger than that when we
lived in a different
place that he had been a victim of um
from Neighbors that he had been
sodomized and and you know raped by kids
in the neighborhood and and he had been
through a lot of trauma that he still it
it's something he has a lot of struggle
with today but sarah sarah sarah sarah
he's not on the phone with me today you
are no he's not
yeah what happened to you was
wrong for sure
no what happened to you is wrong oh and
I've and my ex my
ex-husband
um he he
did let me let me you don't have to go
into it all you know what I'm talking
about right no I do and okay hold on
hold hold hold hold on you know okay so
listen
listen the alarms going off inside of
you please please listen to them
okay
they are I'm I
am I also am just
afraid of not for not because I don't
want to protect my kids but there's a
part of me that is just afraid of taking
on that battle with
him be
because of
the emotional abuse in all that went on
in our marriage Sarah if you don't stand
up for your daughter who's going to
stand up for her I know I
know what happened to you was wrong what
your husband did to you your ex-husband
did to you was evil and
[Music]
wrong and if you notice I didn't tell
you to take him on all by yourself I
told you to kindly let him know I
wouldn't say kindly to let him know
you're bringing in everybody you can
and I'm willing to accept any nonsense
you want to throw my way because what
happened to me is not going to happen to
my
daughter true and maybe your alarms are
are more sensitive than others because
of what you've experienced great I'm
still going to listen to them
anyway yeah I grew up in Houston where
there were hurricanes all the time and
I'm the weekend after a bunch of
tornadoes that just came through town
here in Nashville when the sirens go off
I
overreact cuz I've been there sure yeah
right I've been there right and a lot of
people lost everything this past
weekend right yeah and so it's not that
my alarms were wrong they just were off
this time
fine but I would contact a therapist I
would contact the school
I would let him know if this boy isn't
out of that if they're not in different
Arrangements by the end of today you're
going to call child protective services
and let them know exactly what you've um
went through what what your daughter has
said and will it cause a stir ABS
freaking
lutely will your daughter at eight years
old maybe say Mom I had to go meet with
so and so and this maybe will your
ex-husband talk crap about you to your
daughter and she's going to repeat some
of it to you maybe maybe probably not
but
maybe well I think that already happens
it does it does it does but I want you
to ask the question if you don't stand
up for her who
will yeah who
will
okay yeah will you call a counselor by
the end of today and set up an
appointment for you and your daughter
yeah sure I mean we already I have
established
um myself and my other daughter already
at a place so I can do that that is easy
I want you to call and ask for a
forensic interview because you think
something may have
happened okay and you can tell them I
have my own childhood experiences with
this so I may be overreacting but this
stuff happened and every bit of every
alarm I have went off okay and I want
you
to it's not it's I wouldn't run from
it
for the sake of my eight-year-old
daughter I'll burn it all
down and by the way if you're my friend
and I think something's going
wrong and I ask you about it directly I
challenge you on it
directly my goodness I hope you would be
like man absolutely I'm glad you were
you were standing up for that 8-year-old
girl it didn't happen but man good for
you I remember a great story where a kid
a dad was carrying a kid into a store
and the kid was kicking and screaming
and kicking and screaming and somebody
walking out of the store stopped them
and talked to the
kid and it ended up being that it was
just a kid throwing a temper tantrum
with the dad taking her into a store but
the Dad instead of getting mad and
indignant asked the stranger or told the
stranger hey thank you for getting
involved because if somebody ever
happens to be taking my daughter into a
store trying to kidnap her run away with
her I hope somebody will intervene like
you did thank
you and if your ex-husband is such an
utter
scumbag that he'd rather bury his head
in the sand or rather punish
you by sticking her in that room and not
picking up on the signs when she starts
walking around with different clothes on
starts saying things that are very un
eight-year-old or maybe that's an
8-year-old statement but it should be
challenged
man I'm sorry Sarah
sorry call
everybody we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else in the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right we're back um those those
calls always need a
second
so as wrap up today's show we're going
to do this and am I the problem yes
let's do it Kelly all right so hey hold
on hold on this the day after the
Cowboys ran the Eagles out of the
stadium can we just all take a moment
and celebrate oh I'm so tired today and
it was so very worth it and it was
amazing and we played amazingly right
now we're both we're tied in the
division I love how you keep making this
plural we we yeah you know my team and I
I did a lot from the courtesy of your
couch and in a state several States over
you y'all really got it done we did we
did me me and the boys um we right now
we're
tied um but unfortunately if if we both
went out then they're still ahead
because they've won one more division
game but regardless they won't win out
and they were so mad last night and I
loved every second of that yeah it felt
good yeah it felt good it felt real good
yeah I even uh told my wife hey I'm not
going to bed I'm going to go upstairs
and watch watch a football game and
she's like what happened to my husband
what are you doing I was like I just I
need to know on this one yep also Jaylen
Johnson haha that's just an inside joke
okay to a guy that listens to this show
all right haha all right all right so am
I the problem yes uh I don't have this
guy's name and it's kind of lengthy so
I'm gonna reward it a bit let's just
call him Ben Ben all right so
Ben would like to know um I purchased my
late father's pickup from my mom back in
March and I've been letting my roommates
use it until they have enough money for
a car of their own Ben here drives a
truck for a living and he's only home a
few days of the week so he lets them use
it as much as they want now his brother
is having some mechanical issues with
his car and has been asking to use the
pickup I said that was fine but I
requested very politely that he clear it
with the roommate when he was planning
to use it so that there wasn't any
overlap of who was going to be using it
the brother's mad and the brother says
since the truck originally belonged to
Dad to his father even though brother
has now bought it that he has first
rights to use it without having to clear
it with the roommate so he's wanting to
know am I the problem since I purchased
it because he wasn't given the truck he
purchased it am I the problem for being
doing what I want with the pickup as the
great Jerry Springer would
say you are not the
owner does that apply there
well except he said you're not the
follow here's the deal no nobody gets a
vote except for the guy who bought the
truck he can do whatever he wants to
with it and brother is like well one
time Dad does you don't have a claim to
it you have no say in it at all you
didn't buy the truck your brother did if
y'all had gone havies which would have
been stupid but if y'all had done that
then you would but you don't have a
claim to it so you came growling to your
brother can I borrow a truck for free
that I don't own and he was like well I
promised it to these guys
alas no you're not the problem your
little brother is so in this case Ben's
right way to go Ben thank you it's about
time you're um you're always right
actually so there you go that was
recorded I love that you're just G to
clip that and play it back to me all
time his ringtone now 100% your wife's
gonna say something and you're gonna be
like H hang on second beep there you go
B you're always right there you go yeah
yep yeah I mean do you think so I agree
he bought the TR it'd be one thing if if
it even if Dad had left it to the boys
or dad left it to you to you but still
if that's you know where the legal
ownership lies and that like he says my
truck my rules he says that in here and
that's true because and his bigger
concern here is actually not even should
I let him it's I work on the road I I
drive a truck for a living I've asked
you to contact my roommate and for y'all
to work it out but you're too immature
to do that because you just think you
deserve it you're entitled to it and to
me which just shows the brother is just
immature correct immature Cur entitled
so yep you're not the problem you're a
good brother immature much like the some
of the Philadelphia Eagles who last
night got angry and threw some Hissy
Fits like Patrick Mahomes did
yesterday hey I'm I'm a Red Raider dude
I got to I got he thw a little temper
tantrum he having a bad day it's all
right whatever all right hey thanks for
listening to the show stay in school
don't do drugs be nice to one another
and for cry out loud go
Cowboys